Match each function
to its interval
as it appears on
the graph below.
There will be
functions and intervals
left over when you are finished.
So we have this
crazy-looking graph here.
And what we want to do is think
about what expressions define
the different parts
of this graph.
So if we thought,
for example, that
in the interval between where
x is greater than or equal to 3
and x is less than 7, that
this is being defined by 1/x,
we would drag this into
that just like that.
So to help us think
through it, I've
copy and pasted this thing
onto our scratch pad.
And let's just go
interval by interval.
So this starts at x is
greater than negative 4,
not greater than or equal to.
Or we could say it starts at
negative 4 is less than x--
not less than or equal to,
because the function is not
defined at negative 4.
We have an open circle here.
But let's see what a
good candidate expression
is for this part
of the function.
So to do that, let's just find
some nice, well-defined points
here.
So it looks like
we have that point
over there is the point negative
2 comma-- looks like 1/2.
We have the point here,
which is negative 1 comma 1.
And those look
like two good ones.
So let's see which of
these seem to work,
at least for those points.
Maybe we can rule out some.
So 1/x-- so let's see.
If x is negative 2, 1/x would be
negative 1/2, not positive 1/2.
So this isn't being used to
define this first section.
So we can rule that out for
at least the first section.
Now let's see.
f of x is equal to negative 1/x.
Now, this looks pretty good.
Negative 1 over negative
2 is positive 1/2,
so it works for that.
Negative 1 over negative 1 is 1.
So this right over
here seems to work
for at least this interval.
So it seems to work.
We're doing negative 1/x.
And it seems to work
even after that,
where we have the point right
over here, 1, negative 1.
Negative 1 over 1 is negative 1.
And over here, you
have 2, negative 1/2,
which is also consistent
with this right over here.
So I would throw this
one-- and so this function
works from the interval
negative 4 is less than x,
which is less than
or equal to 2.
So that's this interval
right over here.
So let's actually fill that in.
So that is-- actually,
you can't see it.
It's off the screen right now.
That is that interval
right over there.
Now let's get back to
my little scratch pad.
Now, our function is not
defined for x between 2 and 3.
But then starting at 3, the
function gets defined again.
And let's do the same thing.
Let's look at some
interesting points
that might prove valuable.
So this point right
over here-- actually,
let me do it in magenta.
You have this point, which
is the point 3, negative 2.
You have this point right over
here, which is interesting,
5 comma 2.
So let's test some
of these points out
and see which of these work.
Well, 1/x definitely
doesn't work.
1/5 is not 2.
Negative 1 over x doesn't work.
Negative 1 over 5 is not 2.
1 over 5 squared is not 2.
1/2 times 5 plus 5
to the third power--
that's 10 to the third power.
That's 1,000 times 1/2.
That's 500.
This goes to 502, not 2.
So we're going to rule
this one out, too.
So let me rule it
out for the interval
that we now care about.
We now care about this interval,
or this part of the function.
So let's see.
If we have 5 here-- 5 minus 5 is
0, to the third power is still
0, times 1/2 is
still 0, plus 2 is 2.
So this point is consistent with
this function right over here.
Now, let's see.
Does that work
for 3, negative 2?
3 minus 5 is negative 2, to
the third power is negative 8,
times 1/2 is negative
4, plus 2 is negative 2.
So this looks like a
pretty good candidate.
Let's just make sure we
can rule this one out, too.
Let's see.
5 comma 2-- let's see.
5 plus 5 is 10, squared
is 100, times 1/2 is 50.
52, not 2, so we can rule
this one out, as well.
So it looks pretty clear that
we could use this expression
to define the
interval x is greater
than or equal to 3 and less than
7, not less than or equal to.
It's not defined at 7.
So we could use this for this
interval right over here.
So let's go back to
the actual exercise.
And so we said this one for
this interval right over here.
And let's make sure that we got
it right So check our answer,
and we did.